drinnen bleiben oder nicht der bundestag
streitet über den sinn der geplanten
ausgangssperren im
infektionsschutzgesetz laschet oder
söhne cdu und csu suchen noch immer den
pfad zu einem gemeinsamen kandidaten
fürs kanzleramt
und neue regeln für verkehrssünder die
verschärfung für fahrverbote ist vom
tisch dafür wird es künftig deutlich
teurer
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg bekommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem freitag
sport gibt es auch nachher mit norbert
lehmann einen schönen erfolg
es betrifft uns alle massiv das geplante
neue infektionsschutzgesetz ganz schnell
soll es jetzt mit bundesweit
einheitlichen regeln die explodierenden
corona zahlen bremsen
im bundestag wurde es heute erstmals
beraten mit großer heftigkeit die einen
wollen schneller schulen schließen den
anderen geht die nächtliche
ausgangssperre zu weit aus berlin thomas
reich hat die debatte ist gerade mal ein
paar minuten alt das hätte das reizwort
zum ersten mal ausgangs beschränkungen
sind keine neue erfindung sondern im
aktuell geltenden infektionsschutz
witzige zwischenrufe der afg nicht die
letzten an diesem tag merkel versucht
den eingriff in freiheitsrechte zu
rechtfertigen
denn der nach 13 monaten pandemie eine
lektion doch wirklich gelernt haben dann
ist dass diese das virus verzeiht keine
halbherzigkeiten dass merkel umgekehrt
viel liegengelassen habe in der pandemie
das wirft die opposition hier vor
die afg glaubt zudem der gesetzentwurf
sei ein rückfall in
obrigkeitsstaatliches denken
ausgangssperren sind unverhältnismäßig
und verfassungswidrig für millionen von
menschen die nicht so privilegiert boden
die zum beispiel mitglieder des
bundeskabinetts sind sie die hölle
auch der wissenschaftliche dienst des
bundestages hat zweifel ob
ausgangssperren verfassungsgemäß sind
geben so die liberalen da wird es laut
bei der union entschuldigen sie bitte
herr kollege brinkhaus in dieser
situation verfassungsrechtliche bedenken
an zu machen die wir das tun das sollten
sie eher schätzen lindner beruft sich
gar auf lauterbach mit dem ihnen sonst
wenig ein
der fühlt sich falsch verstanden und
verteidigt ausgangssperren
in keinem land ist es gelungen eine
welle mit einer b 17 mutation nochmal in
den griff zu bekommen ohne dass man
nicht auch und nicht alleine ohne dass
man nicht auch das instrument der
ausgangs beschränkungen und nicht
sperren genutzt hätte für die grünen
kommt dass notbremsen gesetz zu spät
bund reicht nicht aus wir wollen ein
gesetz nicht wartet übrigens bis die
schule gänzlich in flammen steht bevor
jemand nach dem feuerlöscher greift erst
hat eine instanz von 200 zu handeln ist
zu spät sie sind nicht mal in der lage
dieses gesetz rein zu schreiben
das war doch bitteschön testen muss
bevor man sich am arbeitsplatz auffällt
warum schreiben sie das nicht rein
wissen sie was ich continental weil sie
den unternehmerverbänden im winter
hängen
das ist die tatsache die opposition
drängt nun auf änderungen eine andere
frage dagegen klärte sich heute schon
merkel bekam die erste impfung mit
astrazeneca was bringen ausgangs
beschränkungen wirklich dass es nicht
nur im bundestag umstritten an seinem
stern hat sich unter fachleuten umgehört
ein qubit intensiv patient wird verlegt
abflug aus jena in thüringen insgesamt
sechs corona kranke werden von hier in
andere kliniken in deutschland gebracht
die intensivstation in jena komplett
ausgelastet die situation spitzt sich
dramatisch zu wir haben engpässe bei der
versorgung zum beispiel von patienten
mit tumoren leiden mit akuten herz
kreislauferkrankungen das bedrohliche
situation kontakte jetzt weiter
reduzieren fordert der klinikchef nur
wie der ausgangssperre in der nacht eine
maßnahme die politik und wissenschaft
spaltet nach neun nicht mehr raus hilft
das ob eine solche maßnahme nicht auch
seitens der bevölkerung eher als die
sanierung empfunden wird finde ich
durchaus überlegenswert ich und wir
wissen von der deutschen gesellschaft
für suchtforschung dass wir freien
wesentlichen keine infektionen haben
nachmittags oder nachts spazieren
virologisch egal
nicht egal aber so experten wenn mit dem
rausgehen kontakte entstehen
ausgangssperren könnten durchaus größere
treffen
abend verhindern berechnen mobilitäts
forscher das wird bei uns dann auch
quantitativ zu einer reduktion der
ansteckung und zwar eine erwert
reduktion 0,1 was nicht so viel creme
wassergefährt 25 prozent dessen sind was
wir brauchen damit wir die
geschäftstätigkeit kontrollieren können
kontrolle über die virus lage das ziel
doch die ausgangssperren sind auch
juristisch problematisch beispiel von
heute in mainz hat ein gericht die
geltende nächtliche regel gestoppt
ausgangssperren greifen tief in
grundrechte von bürgern ein
in die allgemeine handlungsfreiheit und
dürfen deswegen nicht einfach so
verhängt werden weil es ein bisschen
hilft wenn sie müssen wirklich zwingend
erforderlich sei nach aktueller
rechtslage um eine verschlimmerung der
korona pandemie vorzubeugen
die pandemie politik im land bleibt also
kompliziert und auch umstritten
aktuell sehen die korona zahlen so aus
innerhalb eines tages meldet das
robert-koch-institut 25 1831
neuinfektionen
das sind fast 370 mehr als vergangenen
freitag 247 menschen starben in
verbindung mit dem virus
die bundesweite sieben tage inzidenz
bleibt unverändert bei 160,1 die zahlen
sind hoch die zeit drängt was tun was
halten die menschen hierzulande für
richtig dazu kann matthias fornoff mehr
sagen mit den neuen zahlen aus dem
politbarometer guten abend
fangen wir mit den umstrittenen ausgangs
beschränkungen an wie ist die haltung
grundsätzlich finden es mehr als zwei
drittel der deutschen gut wenn der bund
die korona regeln festlegt aber für eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre sind nur 44
prozent
eine mehrheit von 53 prozent lehnt sie
ab gegen die ausgangssperre sind vor
allem die anhänger von fdp und linke
aber auch bei den anhängern der anderen
parteien gibt es sichtbare kritik mehr
zustimmung gibt es für den plan den
präsenzunterricht an schulen
einzustellen
bei einer incidents über 200 dafür sind
62 prozent 34 prozent finden der
präsenzunterricht sollte trotzdem
weitergehen ganz heißes thema die woche
ist das duell zwischen armin laschet und
markus söder um die kanzlerkandidatur
das team söder beschwört immer wieder
seine guten umfragewerte und bekamen
heute rückenwind so sieht's aus auf die
frage mit wem die union das bessere
ergebnis bei der bundestagswahl
erreichen würde sagen gut zwei drittel
aller befragten mit markus söder
bei den unionsanhängern ist das bild
sogar noch klarer fast drei viertel sind
überzeugt dass so wieder das bessere
ergebnis einfahren könnte armin laschet
liegt da sehr deutlich zurück schadet
der union dieses gerangel um die
kanzlerkandidatur
es schadet bislang nicht jedenfalls
nicht erkennbar in unseren zahlen
schauen wir mal auf die projektion
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 31 prozent plus 3 nach
herben verlusten minus 7 vor drei wochen
spd 14 afd 11 beide -1 fdp 9 linke 7
beide unverändert
die grünen verlieren zwei punkte auf
jetzt 21 prozent eine mehrheit hätte von
den politisch realistischen bündnissen
damit nur schwarz grün für eine
fortsetzung der großen koalition würde
es nicht reichen auch nicht für eine
ampelkoalition oder grün rot rot immer
wieder interessant vielen dank matthias
und das komplette politbarometer mit
matthias fornoff gibt es später im
heute-journal und jederzeit in unserer
app und auf zdf heute alle zahlen und
grafiken zum durchklicken
bis ende der woche würden sie sich
untereinander einigen wer ins rennen
geht das hatten armin laschet und markus
söder anfang der woche zugesagt noch
wird getrommelt für den einen oder eben
den anderen aus unterschiedlichen
beweggründen nicole diekmann gibt uns
einen überblick was sich da gerade tut
der bundestag heute morgen thema das
infektionsschutzgesetz es spricht angela
merkel
die unionsfraktion aber beschäftigt auch
heute etwas anderes wie verfahren mit
der k frage
mit merkels möglicher nachfolge und
einigkeit
das sind zwei starke kandidaten unsere
fraktion ist auch stark und hat auch
über die frage diskutiert am ende muss
die frage aber von der partei
entschieden werden ich glaube wenn es
tatsächlich so der fall sein sollte dass
sich beide kandidaten die exzellente
qualitäten haben nicht einigen können
dann ist die fraktion dass berufene
gremium schlechthin bilder oder laschet
fraktion oder partei
selbst die frage nach dem verfahren sie
ist verfahren denn es gibt keins dafür
aber wachsender gereiztheit das gesamte
parteipräsidium der vorstand steht
hinter armin laschet
und es muss ja jetzt nicht jeder hand
eine erklärung noch mal abgeben aber es
ist eben auch klar dass der druck schon
da ist und eine große erwartungshaltung
in der partei dass diese frage jetzt
nicht in die nächste woche geschoben
wird
doch so klar liegen die dinge nicht
gestern sprach sich reiner haseloff
ministerpräsident von sachsen anhalt für
syrer aus und nahm dies heute nicht
zurück sein sächsischer amtskollege
kritisch äußert sich zwar nicht dafür
aber ein bundestagsabgeordneter aus dem
freistaat bei uns in sachsen ist die
stimmungslage eindeutig sowohl von der
basis als auch im landesvorstand ist die
stimmung klar pro markus söder
nun schaltet sich auch partei grande
wolfgang schäuble ein und wirbt im
gespräch mit der ard für laschet der
druck wächst die gereiztheit auch
zumindest in der partei söder und
laschet aber heißt es haben beide starke
nerven
fragen wir theo koll in berlin was hören
sie ist zu erwarten dass die beiden sich
noch einigen ja das kann noch gelingen
die beiden sollen ja angeblich in
kontakt sein aber selbst hochrangige cdu
leute die wir gesprochen haben tappen im
dunkeln die zeit jedenfalls läuft gegen
armin laschet denn wenn markus söder
nicht nachgibt dann will die
unionsfraktion als einziges gemeinsames
gremium von cdu und csu am dienstag eine
entscheidung erzwingen die vorbereitung
für eine abstimmung laufen da schon und
in der fraktion soll es so hören wir
eine art zweidrittelmehrheit für so
wiedergeben ohne es über höhen zu wollen
erleben wir ja gerade den kampf von zwei
unterschiedlichen demokratischen
verständnisses für armin laschet sind
die gewählten parteigremien entscheidend
für markus söder zählen mehr die eigene
beliebtheit und die damit verbundenen
die chancen also eine art
personalisierter populismus und die cdu
ist zerrissen zwischen diesen beiden
ansätzen und damit auch zwischen den
beiden kandidaten die einschätzung von
theo koll aus berlin vielen dank auf
einem ganz anderen gebiet ist man sich
heute überraschend einig geworden und
zwar bei den bußgeldern für autofahrer
der neue bußgeldkatalog liegt ja seit
rund einem jahr quasi auf eis seit dem
wurde vor allem darüber gestritten wie
schnell ist bei verstößen fahrverbote
geben soll jetzt der kompromiss der
verkehrsminister wer falsch parkt und zu
schnell fährt für den wird es vor allem
teure keine klatsche verkehrssünder die
von der polizei herausgefunden werden
müssen sich auf härtere strafen
einstellen
nach monatelangem gezerre zwischen bund
und ländern heute eine einigung auf zum
teil drastische bußgeld erhöhungen die
verkehrsrowdys werden härter bestraft
aber die verhältnismäßigkeit der
bußgelder ohne zusätzliche fahrverbote
ist gebaut
wir schützen die schwächeren
verkehrsteilnehmer wie radfahrer und
fußgänger besser erleichtern die arbeit
der rettungskräfte und schaffen so mehr
rücksicht im straßenverkehr bestraft
werden sollen vor allem unbelehrbarer
die etwa den sicherheitskräften keine
rettungsgasse frei machen
das soll statt 200 zukünftig 320 euro
kosten
parken im halteverbot steigt von 15 auf
bis zu 55 euro
geschwindigkeits überschreitungen
innerorts um 26 kilometer pro stunde von
100 auf 180 euro die bremer
verkehrssenatorin schäfer die den
kompromiss vorantrieb war zufrieden das
erwarten die menschen auch von uns dass
wir sie wirklich vor solchen rasereien
schützen und da eben auch jemand
durchgreifen und das machen wir jetzt
mit diesen neuen bußgeldkatalog auch der
adac begrüßte die einigung
eine erhöhung der geldbussen macht
punktuell sind und zwar dort wo die
geldbußen viel zu niedrig gewesen sind
wo sie nicht ernst genommen werden dass
er mit zum teil bei parkverstößen wo der
park verstoß billiger ist als das
parkhaus damit endet ein streit der sich
über ein jahr hinzog damals waren
bußgeld erhöhungen wegen eines
formfehlers in der
straßenverkehrsordnung ausgesetzt worden
in den usa wird ein weiterer
polizeieinsatz fragen auf vor zwei
wochen erschoss die polizei in chicago
einen 13-jährigen eine latino die
aufnahmen der körper kameras der
polizisten zeigen jetzt dass adam toledo
seine leeren hände gehoben hatte als ihn
der schuss in die brust traf die polizei
hatte erklärt der junge habe eine waffe
gehabt die bürgermeisterin von chicago
nannte die bilder verstörend und rief
zur ruhe auf
nach hongkong dort bekam die
demokratiebewegung erneut die harte hand
der chinesischen führung zu spüren
ein gericht verurteilte mehrere
prominente dissidenten zu haftstrafen
unter ihnen auch der medienunternehmer
danny lee
der 72 jährige multimillionär bis 14
monate ins gefängnis
er und weitere aktivisten sollen an
nicht genehmigten demonstrationen
teilgenommen und diese auch zum teil
organisiert haben trotz aller gefahr für
sein gewissen eintreten das ist heute
mutig und das war es vor 500 jahren
genauso lange ist es nämlich am
wochenende her dass er hier die ganze
welt veränderte martin luther kaiser
karl der fünfte hatte den aufmüpfigen
theologen nach worms einbestellt luther
sollte seine lehre widerrufen
doch der tat nichts dergleichen und die
reformation nahm ihren lauf
luther habe auf argumente gesetzt
betonte heute bundespräsident steinmeier
kriterien ein moment der dutzende male
verfilmt wurde
martin luther steht in worms vor dem
kaiser und er steht unter druck
der mensch soll seine kritik am
ablasshandel also dem freikauf von
sünden widerrufen
sein eigenes leben steht auf dem spiel
solange ich nicht durch zeugnisse der
schrift oder durch die vernunft
überwinden werde
so lange werde ich nur meinem gewissen
gehorchen
und nichts wieder rund 500 jahre ist das
her
in worms wird heute gefeiert das luther
damals haltung bewies steht vor kaiser
und reich unerschütterlich zu seinen
einsichten zu seinen erkenntnissen und
seinen überzeugungen
wir gedenken einer europäischen
sternstunde des erwachten individuellen
gewissens 2 bronze schuhe markieren den
ort an dem luther damals stand es
sollten große feierlichkeiten in worms
werden die korona bedingt klein
ausfallen
mitte der woche wurde für eine
multimedia inszenierung geprobt die für
die meisten nur am bildschirm zu sehen
sein wird
dennoch luther momente gebe es immer
wieder für jede und jeden dass ich
flagge zeige dass sich haltung zeigen
wenn unrecht passiert das ist etwas was
mich im persönlichen leben treffen kann
oder was sich im persönlichen leben
erleben kann
das hat aber auch etwas was ich in der
öffentlichkeit zum ausdrucken kann
mehr als 100 veranstaltungen sind für
das laufende jahr geplant im juli öffnet
die landesausstellung mit dem titel hier
stehe ich dann so die hoffnung der
organisatoren mit vielen luther
interessierten vor ort in worms ein
wichtiger tag für das britische
königshaus morgen es gilt trotz corona
standesgemäß abschied von prinz philip
zu nehmen um die königstreuen briten
davon abzuhalten nach schloss winzer zu
reisen hat der bürgermeister des kleinen
städtchens dazu aufgerufen zu hause zu
trauern
insgesamt setzt die pandemie der
trauerfeier enge grenzen statt 800 sind
nur 30 gäste geladen
vermutlich sehr im sinne des
verstorbenen prinz philip hatte sich
eine beerdigung ohne großes getue
gewünscht dass in hallein
prinz philip war ein mann des militärs
durch und durch und genauso hat er seine
beerdigung auch geplant natürlich findet
das ganze auf grund der pandemie in viel
kleinerem rahmen statt als ursprünglich
gedacht doch ordentlich geprobt werden
muss natürlich trotzdem sogar jedes
musikstück für die zeremonie hat prinz
philip ausgewählt und da wäre noch
dieser umgebaute und in militärisch grün
gehaltene landrover denn der prinz nach
seinen genauen vorstellungen fertigen
ließ um seinen sack zu transportieren
weniger in seinem sinne ist sicherlich
die tatsache dass die mitglieder des
königshauses entgegen sonstiger
gepflogenheiten wie hier bei der
beerdigung von queen mum 2002 keine
uniformen tragen werden wohl um allen
beteiligten peinlichkeiten zu ersparen
nehmen durch die beiden prinzen ende und
harry aus unterschiedlichen gründen
inzwischen keine royalen pflichten mehr
war und haben daher auch keine
militärischen ehrenämter mehr inne
bekannt wurde inzwischen auch dass an
der beerdigung drei mitglieder des
deutschen zweigs der familie philips
zwei groß neffen und ein kuss des
prinzen teilnehmen werden eine große
ehre bei nur 30 trauergästen
die anteilnahme der briten am tode des
ehemannes der königin ist gross gestern
betrachteten prinz charles und ehefrau
camilla das blumenmeer in der nähe von
schloss windsor und studierten die
trauerbekundungen und die rolls
revanchieren sich mit der
veröffentlichung von fotos aus dem
privaten familienalben die zeichnen land
bild des prinzen als familienmensch eine
art großvater der nation
das zdf überträgt die trauerfeier morgen
ab 15 uhr 10 und jetzt zur
fußball-bundesliga norbert da
hinterlassen die korona fälle bei der
hertha spuren allerdings das komplette
team muss in häusliche quarantäne für 14
tage
deshalb wurden die nächsten drei spiele
der berliner abgesagt die werden im mai
nachgeholt die deutsche fußball liga
prüft jetzt weitere maßnahmen damit
diese so ordnungsgemäß zu ende gespielt
werden kann
erst war nur der trainer positiv dann
der assistent und schließlich auch luke
baku
der stürmer
das hätte eine arbeits quarantäne
bedeutet training und spielbetrieb wäre
noch möglich gewesen
als dann gestern abend der vierte marvin
plattenhardt hinzukam war schluss 14
tage häusliche quarantäne für alle
spiele gegen mainz zeigte und freiburg
müssen verschoben werden da nicht mit
dieser situation sondern wir nehmen sie
komplett an und werden kämpfen um unsere
mindestens saisonziel nämlich den
klassenverbleib dann auch zu sichern
also erstmal trainingsausfall und dann
im mai sechs spiele in vier wochen
die dfl wird sich mit notfall plänen
beschäftigen müssen dann könnten die
verpflichtenden quarantäne
trainingslager für die erste und zweite
liga an den letzten spieltagen in kraft
treten
zum volleyball der feiert berlin seine
elfte deutsche meisterschaft nach dem
dritten sieg in der finalserie gegen den
dauer-rivalen aus friedrichshafen
umkämpft nur der erste satz überragender
akteur der berliner in schwarz benjamin
patch mit beeindruckender schlagkraft
friedrichshafen hatte dem nichts
entgegenzusetzen matchball schon nach
einer stunde 19 minuten zum dreisatzsieg
die berliner trumpften nach mäßiger
saison im finale groß auf wer uns denn
so ein lauf gespielt und viel musik
gespielt und sehr gut gewesen wenn wir
das jahren zusammen so hätten vielleicht
hat man als ich noch ein bisschen mehr
machen können national aber sind sie
wieder die besten zur formel1 zweite
saisonrennen den italienischen die
mullahs heute beim freien training hatte
mercedes wieder einmal die nase vorn
valtteri bottas der schnellste nur eine
hundertstelsekunde hinter ihm sein
teamkollege lewis hamilton weltmeister
max fest dass wir im red bull mit
technischen problemen
ja und sebastian vettel dem ersten
martin musste weil muss weiter aufholen
heute nur
15 am morgen das qualifying am sonntag
die entscheidung
das wetter wird zum wochenende nicht
wirklich schöner aber milder details hat
leicht helfer marietta slomka begrüßt
sie um 10 im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse machen sie sich
noch ein schönes wochenende und bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren lange
kam die strömen und kam auch der wind
aus nördlichen richtungen
das hat sich jetzt aber geändert jetzt
kommt der wind- und auch die strom mehr
so aus nordosten
das ist deswegen bei uns deutlich milder
wird ist allerdings nicht der fall das
sehen sie schon an den
höchsttemperaturen von heute in warschau
waren das sechs grad in berlin 11 grad
aber diese wolken haben zur folge dass
es nachts häufig nicht mehr so ganz
eiskalt wird heute nacht sinken die
temperaturen hier nordosten auf 4 bis 2
grad über schnee am alpenrand geht es
dagegen noch mal in den frost von minus
5 grad deutlich milder bleibt es auf den
ostfriesischen inseln mit plus 5 grad
und so vogel neben zum teil auch die
sterne ganz im westen und auch im süden
im osten dagegen sind diese dichteren
wolken unterwegs und die bringen auch
regen mit zwischen der ostseeküste und
im spreewald und im erzgebirge ist auch
noch schnee dabei das wird uns auch
morgen noch begleiten zumindest mal am
vormittag sonst ändert sich am wetter
eigentlich wenig na ja die sonne kommt
raus hier zwischen der nordseeküste und
vor allen dingen auch westlich des
reichs die temperaturen morgen liegen
noch mal zwischen vier und 13 grad aber
in den nächsten tagen wird es dann
sukzessive ein kleines bisschen milder
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen abend